Pablo escobar was the world's
most successful drug trafficker.
He was also,
it's nice deadly.
During his 17 year reign at the top
of the Colombian cocaine and bar,
he ordered the killings
of thousands of people,
including judges,
ministers of parliaments,
and even presidential candidates.
At the height of his power,
he was raking in over a
million dollars a day.
Yes,
in the end,
he was forced to live as a
fugitive in the Colombian jungle.
Shut down on a rooftop in
the city that he ruled over.
His was an epic fall from grace and this
episode of biographics we go deep into
the south.
American drug dwells to reveal
the true life of Don Pablo
Pablo Emilio Escobar.
Gaviria was born on December the
first 1949 in the small town.
Every now grow 45 minutes from Midian.
Colombia,
his father able was a hardworking,
humble cattle farmer.
One his mother,
her Milda was a school teacher public.
The seconds of seven children was raised
in a middle class environment and a
community that was fueled by
the cocaine and marijuana trade.
Although not everyone's directly
participated in the drug business.
They all had a powerful incentive in
the protection of those that did the
violence.
That was part and parcel of enforcing
the narcotic straight with all around
them.
Before starting school,
the family moved to end avocado,
a small village just outside
of [inaudible] so that her
Milda could establish an
elementary school that Abel sold the farm
and took up a job as a neighborhood to
watch man through hard work at the school.
Her milled,
it soon became a popular
and well respected member
of the community at school.
Pablo proved himself to be
enabled and quick witted students,
although tending toward the Chubby side,
thanks to his love of fast food,
he was talented in all ball sports
with a special love for soccer.
Many of us teachers were
involved in social causes,
especially the struggle for classic
quality and they became very powerful
influences on the young Pablo.
By the time he was in his early teens
public was attending street rallies and
participating in such activities like
throwing rocks at the police probably
became part of a youth culture
movement known as an a day Smoot,
which encouraged young people to thumb
their noses at the established order they
were to do things like disobey their
parents and write their own rules.
Part of this counter cultural movements
involved experimentation with drugs
leading the 13 year old future drug
kingpin to develop an addiction to
marijuana,
which would never leave him.
Okay.
By the age of 16 Pablo had developed into
a plumper shorter youth standing just
over five foot six inches.
He had a round face and
what a slight mustache.
A couple of before
reaching his 17th birthday,
he dropped out of school board with the
straight laced routine and keen to make
his own way in the wells.
After quitting school,
the enterprising pab lobe
started up a bicycle repair shop.
He would prowl the streets,
sends the local dump in
search of discarded bicycle
parts and then use them to
fix bikes are cheap with the money
that he made from this enterprise.
He purchased himself a
Lambretta motorcycle.
Now with a means of foster escape,
he began planning how to make more
money more easily than the by repairing
bicycles for a pittance.
According to legends,
Pablo Foray into crime began with him
stealing headstones from the local
cemetery sounds,
blasting the names from them
and then reselling them.
Pablo then decided though that the root
to quick cash lay in commercial business
rubbery.
He started by scoping
out potential targets.
He would then ride to the target
business on his motorbike,
set Abella cover over his head and rush
to the business with a knife or a gun in
hand,
demanding money,
and then be got out of that.
All of this would happen
in about 30 seconds.
Well,
after a few successful robberies populate,
recruited his cousin to join him.
One would ride the bike and act as the
getaway writer while the other stormed
into the business.
But within a few months,
patty,
they became bored of this and moved
onto bigger and it's easier things.
He established a contact with a rent,
a car dealership.
He would provide him with copies of the
keys to cars that he had just sold along
with the addresses of the buyers.
All the Pablo had to do was turn up at
the address and drive the cars away.
In his late teens,
they public got caught in the act
of stealing one of these cars.
He ended up spending several
months in Lala Dara jail,
which was to him a very
positive life experience.
It was in this jail cause he learns how
to move into bigger criminal activity,
including kidnapping,
drug trafficking.
One SPEC on the street,
Pablo and his cousin,
Gustavo,
went right back to stealing costs.
They built up a collection
of stolen engine parts,
which they would sell off bit by bit.
The bear then took to building race cars
with Pablo competing in local events.
Pablo Ans Garcia weren't the only
ones stealing cars in metagene though,
which led to an extension
of his operation.
He decided to also sell protection so
the people would pay him to ensure that
their car did not get taken.
Ballet was able to provide such a service
because he had developed a reputation
as an unpredictable
and violence young man.
If anyone who didn't money
probably would hire a local thug,
do you kidnap that person?
He would then ransom him for whatever
was owed to him from time to time.
He would even have that person kills when
the ransom was paid simply to engender
fear in those he dealt with before
long paddlow decided to specialize in
kidnappings for their own sake,
along with his cousin and
future brother in law.
He nabbed a rich businessman by
the name of Diego Acca Varia.
This man was intensely disliked by
many of the poor workers in Midian.
He were being laid off
droves by industrialists
like him despite the family.
Okay.
In the $50,000 ransom demands.
Echo varia was beaten,
strangles and then dumped in a ditch
even though he had just committed a
terrible crime.
His choice of victim made
Pablo hugely popular.
Among the common folk have
met a yin in a strange way.
They saw the killings as public
striking a blow for social equality.
Sorry.
In 1971 the 22 year old Pavlo began
working for [inaudible] based Contraband
Dealer Alvara Prieto underappreciated.
Pablo was doing a modest amount
of drug trafficking before long.
However,
he decided that he wanted more of
a slice of the pie for himself.
He drove his stolen running four to
Ecuador and bought five kilograms of
Peruvian cocaine paste successfully
passing through a number of police and
military checkpoints.
He returned to Midian where
he processed the cocaine.
He next contacted fellow criminals.
The Ochoa brothers just set up a sale
to a local cocaine chief called fattier
Restrepo.
The sale netted Pavlo close to
$100,000 far surpassing anything he had
previously done and setting himself up
firmly on the path to becoming a high end
drug dealer within two months.
February Restrepo had been murdered.
Suddenly there was a new man of the head
of the [inaudible] cocaine operation,
and that was Pablo Escobar.
Now importantly,
it has never been conclusively proven.
The Pablo murdered Restrepo,
but that was what everyone
involved believed.
The majority of people working for
Restrepo were upper class dandies.
They were pretty frightened by Pablo
and the ruthless hoodlums that he
surrounded himself with.
Shortly after muscling his
way to the top of the median,
cocaine's indicas.
Pablo married 15 year old Maria,
Victoria,
Helena Vallejo,
so now Pablo,
he was 26 years old.
He had a wife,
he had wealth and he had power.
It really seems like the sky
was going to be the limit.
The cocaine trade from Panama through
Columbia and into the United States boomed
in the late 1970s with most of it
being trafficked through Escobar's
organization under pablet with the
cocaine industry became streamlined.
He purchased a fleet of
airplanes including a Leer
jet transport the drugs into
the United States where there was an
inexhaustible supply of willing buyers.
Two months after his wedding though
Pablo and four others were arrested,
resounding from a drug run to Ecuador,
drug enforcement agents founds 39 kilos
of cocaine isn't in the spare tire of
their truck.
Vast amounts of coke would
see Pablo put away for a long,
long time.
His first tactic and getting out of
the mess was to bribe the trial judge.
The offer,
however,
was flatly rejected.
How beloved then had his team recently,
the judges backgrounds,
they discovered that he had a brother
who was a lawyer and that the two men did
not get on.
The lawyer was contacted and offered a
huge amounts to represent Pablo in the
case.
As suspected,
the judge was forced to recuse himself
due to the conflict of interest and the
new judge.
Well,
he had less scruples
about taking the payments.
He accepted the bribe and Pablo
and his cohorts walked free.
Exorbitant amounts of money.
We're now pouring into Colombia
with deposits in the countries.
Four major banks doubling between 1976
and 1980 [inaudible] was then able to use
his millions to take possession
of every step of his operation.
Traveling to Peru,
Bolivia,
and it's Panama,
and buying up all the cultivation
farms and processing plants.
He was also able to buy off enforcement
agencies in every country developing a
ruthless policy which came
to be known as silver or led.
If officials didn't accept his bribe,
they could expect to end up debt.
By 1980 Pablo was at the absolute height
of his power with every law enforcement
agency on his payroll.
He was the unofficial king of Midian.
He wasn't the only cocaine,
Impresario and Columbia,
but he certainly was the most successful.
He owns multiple mansions.
He had racing cars,
helicopters and planes,
and was constantly surrounded by
bodyguards and hangers on cocaine.
Money absolutely transformed many in
with discos and high and restaurants
opening up all over the city.
One of paddleloons passions was soccer
and now he was able to indulge it.
He paid to have fields levels and sorted
and lights installed so that he and his
crew could play at nighttime.
He also employed professional game
callers to announce the matches as if they
were an FAA Cup final in
1979 papillary wheels,
a lavish country estate.
On a 7,400 acre ranch,
80 miles outside of Midean and dws,
Hacienda Las and Apollos.
He brought exotic animals from all
over the worlds to populate the farm,
built six swimming pools and a huge
mansion that could sleep 100 guests at the
same time that he was indulging his
every materialistic women private Pablo
began tending to his public image.
He constantly denied that he was
involved in any illicit activity,
portraying a formal,
likable persona and
appearing humble and polite.
He consciously cultivated the image
that he was a freedom fighter for the
underprivileged,
setting himself up as an
alternative to the establishment.
He also poured millions of dollars
into social construction programs.
Between 1980 and 1982 Pablo did more
to help the poor and meti in than the
Colombian government had ever done.
One of his most popular
initiatives was a housing projects.
There was called Barrio Pablo Escobar,
where houses were bills,
and it's given us a families who had
previously been sheltering in shacks.
The city dump this and a host of other
projects easily made him the most popular
citizen in [inaudible] in private.
Pablo conducted himself
in an understated manner.
He spoke softly and was generally relaxed
and casual with the people around him.
He was also hugely
self-indulgence with food,
with drink and with women,
and he considered himself
a law unto himself.
As an example of this,
on one occasion when an employee
was found to have stolen from him,
Pablo had him brought before him bound
hand and first and then kicked it into
the swimming pool.
They can everyone watch as the man drowns
with his popularity among the masses
firmly established and his dominance over
his empire assured.
The next logical step
for Pablo was politics.
His path to and legitimate office
began in 1978 when he was elected as a
substitute city counselor in met a
year in 1980 he gave his personal and
financial support to the formation of
a new national political movements,
the new Liberal Party.
Then in 1982 he ran for and was elected
to Congress all the as a substitute who
attended when the primary delegate
from that a yin was unavailable,
a major perk of being elected to
Congress was that now Pablo had judicial
immunity,
meaning that he could not be convicted
for any crime under Colombian law.
The position also afforded
him a diplomatic visa,
which he made you solve to regularly
take his family on trips to the United
States.
On one of these trips,
he purchased an $8 million
mansion in Miami Beach,
Florida.
So public now had political legitimacy
to go with his massive wealth.
And the next acquisition you
made was a personal army,
one of friends of the family.
He was kidnapped by m 19 gorillas.
He created a private militia
to hunt down these rebels.
Pablo Blues Army was known
as death to kidnappers.
So Pablo is wider exposure as a
result of his political office.
When it was the beginning
of his downfall in Midian,
Pablo,
he was viewed as this Robin Hood figure,
but when he'd tried to gain the
favor of polite Colombian society,
he was not welcomed.
They viewed him as what he really was a
ruthless cocaine king with absolutely no
scruples when he turns up to take a
seat in Congress as an alternate for the
first time on August the 16th 1983
with a bevy of bodyguards in tow,
he was first denied entry
for not wearing a tie.
He quickly got hold of one and
swept since the Pax Chamber.
He slumps down in his allocated
seats and began nervously to bite his
fingernails.
Immediately the chamber president stood
up and demanded that all body guards be
removed from the chamber.
Pablo nodded and just thugs
left the room within minutes.
Justice Minister Rodrigo Lara was on
his feet defending a claim of corruption
that had been brought against him.
Laura pointed his finger at Pablo and
stated we have a congressman who was born
in a very poor area himself,
very,
very poor and afterwards
through a stage of business,
deals in bicycles and other things.
Appears with a gigantic fortune with
nine Blaine's three hangers at the media
unit airport and creates the movement
death to kidnappers while on the other
hands,
mountains charitable organizations with
which she tries to bribe a needy and
unprotected people.
Now there are investigations going in the
United States of which I cannot inform
you here tonight in the House on the
criminal conduct of Pablo Escobar.
Now,
Pablo said nothing in the house,
but when he left he was besieged
by reporters breaking free.
He stormed off through his lawyer.
He informs Laura that if he did not
present evidence of his claims within 24
hours,
he would face legal action.
Laura willingly obliged
and then the coming days,
the newspapers were filled with all sorts
of revelations about Pablos criminal
activity.
Pablo was now persona non
grata in political circles.
He was kicked out of the new Liberal
Party and theU s embassy revoked has
diplomatic visa.
The Catholic church also renounced their
supportive and the governments even
seized 85 of the exotic
animals on Pabla his ranch,
claiming that they had
entered the country illegally.
Pablo,
his political career is now in ruins.
Even worse for Pablo be Colombian
governments at Laura's urgings was fast
tracking an extradition treaty with the
u s that would see him trying in America
for selling cocaine in that country.
In May of 1984 justice minister Lara
was shot seven times while riding in his
chauffer driven limousine,
but Pablo had powerful enemies.
US President Ronald Reagan had announced
a major crackdown on the cocaine trade
with the death of Laura.
The Colombian government were willing to
cooperate with American authorities to
go after narco kingpins and Pablo.
He was the biggest of them all.
The killing of Lara also turns much of
the Colombian population against Pavlay
by this act.
He had declared war on
the state for Pablo.
The heat was too much to bear and he
skip the country taking a helicopter to
Panama City.
Yet,
despite being offered asylum in Panama,
just the year before,
Pablo and his cronies were
not welcomed by the authority.
After just a few weeks in exile Pablo,
he was desperate to get back home.
He made overtures to the
Colombian government's
drafting a proposal whereby he
would go straight and he uses massive
influence to read Columbia of drug
trafficking,
provided that he could retain his
possessions in Midian and that he would be
exempt from arrest or
extradition to the United States.
There's other though it was
roundly rejected when the
Panamanian army rated one
of the labs that he had situated
on the Colombian border.
He fled Panama for Nicaragua.
Meanwhile,
he was hearing that his
absence from Columbia was
undermining his control of the
median cartel,
the kidnapping of a 73 year old father.
Well,
that was a step too far.
Pablo audit,
a killing frenzy throughout in
dozens of suspected kidnappers.
They would just gunned down.
Finally,
they gave in and Pablo,
his old man was released with
no ransom ever being paid.
Okay.
In the midst of the carnage
over his father's kidnapping,
Pablo returned to Columbia.
He was now determined to take on the
state with everything that he had around
Medina.
He was untouchable having
bought off every official.
This allows him,
although being the most wanted man in
the country to move around the town
freely.
Public vengeful focus during the mid
eighties was squarely centered on the
judiciary,
especially judges who supported the
extradition treaty with the U s.
During this time,
more than 30 judges were shot dead.
Then in November of 1985 the gorilla grip,
I'm 19 having been paid
$1 million by Pavlo,
stormed the palace of justice and
how's the entire supreme court hostage.
They demanded that the government
renounced the extradition treaty in the
resulting siege.
11 of the 24 justices along with
40 of the rebels were killed.
By the beginning of 1988 killings were
being reported on an almost daily basis.
Martial law was declared to
around the state from toppling.
On August the 18th 1989 pueblos kill
squads gun down both the front running
presidential candidates,
Luis Galen,
and say state police chief.
In the following four months,
the Colombian government apprehended
and sent more than 20 suspected drug
traffickers to the United States to stand
trial and national police units with
stations to Metta Une
specifically to hunt down Pablo.
Within the first month,
30 of the 200 men station
there had been killed.
Pablo was evading as governments
and inflicting enormous casualties,
but he was a man constantly on the run.
He always stayed a step
ahead of his pursuers,
but he was growing tired of the
constant relocations that were needed.
Eventually he was driven to negotiate.
Pablo agreed to put an end to all the
violence to stop all criminal activity and
hand himself in.
In exchange,
he demands it preferential treatments in
a prison of his choosing and a reduced
settlement.
The government had already revoked the
extradition treaty to the U s with its
1991 constitution,
so he didn't have to worry about being
sent to America and it's with all of
that.
Pablo was duly arrested and duty tried.
He began his sentence as low catty
drought prison in June of 1991 but this,
well,
it was like no other prison on earth.
If featured a football
pitch to QC and a bar,
all of the prison guards
were pub Lowe's employees.
The prison cells were more like hotel
suites and the food that Pablo and his
fellow inmates.
It was prepared by chefs who were
brought in from the finest restaurants.
But after a few months,
accounts began to reach official channels
that Pablo was continuing to pursue
his criminal activities from the prison.
This was a violation of the surrender
agreements and to move as were put in
place to sees him and move
him to a regular prison.
Pablos connections enabled him to get a
wind of the plan and he escaped before
authorities.
It get to him,
okay,
Pablo is back on,
but now the u s and Colombian authorities
were joins buying a vigilante group
known as the Los Padres,
which stood for people
persecuted by Pablo Escobar.
Last pap has carried
out a ruthless campaign,
killing as many as 300 people who were
connected to Pablo and disorganization.
Following his escape.
Public was constantly on the run.
Most of his closest associates were dad
and his organization was totally falling
apart.
He was spending nights
sleeping in the jungle,
afraid to speak on the radio
or even to answer the phone.
Finally,
they fake caught up with Pablo Escobar.
On December the second 1993 members of
a Colombian search bloc team attracted
down to her house in Los Olivos
in marine via radio intercepts.
The search bloc team smashed through the
heavy steel door with a sledgehammer,
whereupon six of them
rushed into the house.
It was then the shooting started with
Pablo in the house was his most loyal
bodyguard known as Lehman.
They both bolted from the front room
and made their way up into the roof.
The six search bloc members
along with others outside port,
a massive barrage of
gunfire at their targets.
Lemon was hit several times in the
back and tumbled to the ground below.
Then Pablo went down.
He was struck several
times in the leg and torso,
but the fatal shot penetrated his
skull on confirming his targets.
The leader of the operation
spoke excitedly into his
radio viva like Columbia.
We have just killed Pablo Escobar,
but had they,
Pablo had always told his
family that if cornered,
he would commit suicide by
placing a bullet in his skull.
Many people believe that he did so one
smaller escaping the clutches of the
Colombian authorities.
So I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday
when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive over
there on the right and as always,
thank you for watching.